writing reading typing texting written
language is just one of those things
that's always been around it's a natural
way for you to use words it's a given
but there's something you've forgotten
it's understandable after all it's been
a very long time a long time since no
one on the planet knew how to write our
story starts with a legend the tale of
Thoth and Thamus no that's not a lisp
ear hearing Thoth and Thamus Thoth and
Thamus after the Egyptian god Thoth
invents writing he runs to King famis to
share this discovery but to his chagrin
the king isn't impressed at all looking
down his nose he starts pontificating on
the destructive power of this newfangled
technology Oh clever Thoth this
invention will produce forgetfulness in
the minds of learners with the neglect
of their memory because their trust in
writing comes from strange external
marks and not their own internal recall
the drug you've discovered isn't a
memory enhancer but a mentioning
enhancer and your offering students
pretend wisdom not truth this sounds
strange it's easy for you and your world
full of writing to dismiss Themis but
hear him out he brings you back to the
early days of writing when it was the
hot new thing and like many other
inventions not everyone was on board ok
so let's say for the sake of argument
you don't want writing what are the
alternative technologies you could bust
out your abacuses they'll help with
counting and doing complex calculations
maybe you prefer icons ritualized images
that help you relate to culturally
significant figures events and attitudes
the key foo is in a May
an Incan information storage system
using cords colors and knots oh and
don't overlook rote memorization a basic
option sure but it's really useful in
preliterate societies where sentences
can be memorized and recited by the
thousands your brain is bigger than you
think perhaps you prefer petroglyphs
rock carvings with major cultural ties
that may refer to nearby places or
animals
watch out writing we're getting
uncomfortably close all of these
inventions helped humans keep track of
their thoughts so what makes writing
different
what's theme is afraid of let's talk
some Ness embeddedness these things are
all embedded in minds tasks rituals
events cultures rip them from those
contexts and you rip out their
expressive heart thoughts drug doesn't
come with so many strings attached it
will de-embed you letting you record any
specific thought and letting future
generations read it in any context so
human was Themis right is writing an
unnatural intrusion or do you want to
swallow thought spill and see for
yourself what we actually unleashed when
we invented writing
LaFrance
17,000 years ago it's cold out and
getting colder possibly dangerous to
this maybe France and this may be the
history of writing but there's nothing
for you here
until you take shelter in a nearby cave
and see how creative some of your
ancestors really were drawing on their
enlarging brains and a long prehistory
of building ever more complex tools
these early artists took to etching and
painting beautiful visual
representations of the animals around
them these aren't words they're not
stories they're pictures early pictures
like these start to become very routine
not necessarily depicting the world but
marking and standing for things a place
to hunt a place to eat
these are pictographs the story gets
sketchy here but it's important to
notice that pictographic symbols like
these petroglyphs rock carvings weren't
words they weren't language but they
became more than personal and communal
artistic expressions they became regular
and repeatable possibly mapping to
specific things and for that these
pictographs earned themselves the fancy
label of proto writing many pictographs
have an intuitive giveaway quality they
look like drawings of the things they
represent draw me a human easy draw me a
horse sure a river there it is but how
do you clearly and simply draw less
tangible ideas like playing around or
taking it easy or don't even think about
it
uh-oh watch out for this major moments
in the history of writing meet metonymy
this principled fellow lets you
represent a general nebulous idea with
the related pictogram or part of a
pictogram or a pictogram combo that's
pretty specific and obvious ancient
stick human is a regular old pictogram
if you cut off sticks legs you can get
across the general idea what walking
removing what about a man leaning
against a tree what's the idea here
making it easy resting these are
ideographs symbols for ideas and
concepts in some sense all of these
drawings express ideas the concept of a
horse concept of a human so they're all
ideograph ik but with a little
imagination and a lot of time extended
ideographs let you cut and combine basic
pictographs to be far more expressive
and abstract just when you're ready to
grab that chisel and get your
pictographic and ideographic carving on
someone more inventive than you comes
along your pictures and ideas aren't
enough for her gone are the days of
Lascaux the world outside this cave is
changing she says crops cities rulers
markets and she needs a way to keep
track of it all she likes your icons she
can use them for goats and pots fields
and even long walks through the desert
but she has an incredible practical
streak she takes those goats and those
pots and starts to tell you the items
she's recording one goat she says then
two goats three goats four goats notice
what she's done these aren't simple
depictions anymore they're not just
ideas she's reading one word for each
symbol she's encoding language let's
slow down here because it's hard to
overstate the importance of this major
moment in the history of writing these
goat counts are word symbols now
logographs pictographs can be visualized
ideographs can be imagined but
logographs can be directly and
consistently read logographic systems
emerge and flourish in the early
civilizations of Mesopotamia Egypt China
and Mexico characters for people animals
land crops hundreds even thousands of
logographs for everything under the Sun
and Moon including the Sun and the moon
even after all these millennia if you
squint hard enough you can still pick
out the symbols scratched into weathered
artifacts bearing the world's early
script a Chinese turtle an Egyptian
house a Sumerian head a Sumerian head
eating bread a Mayan Jaguar and in each
of these places in all of these
languages these were read as words we
know what these logographs mean and we
put that meaning into words the world is
now in a race to fill itself with
logographs but which humans started this
craze
well the Mesoamericans started writing
more than 29 hundred years ago some
Chinese characters are at least 3200
years old writing popped up in Crete
4000 years ago but the to clear
contenders are Egyptian hieroglyphs and
Sumerian cuneiform both a whopping 5,000
years old minimum it's common to say
that the Egyptians stole the idea of
writing from Mesopotamia and just came
up with their own glyphs common but not
demonstrated for a while mana Genesis
made sense this is the idea that one
civilization was king of all the writing
that writing started once in Mesopotamia
where people pressed a stylus into wet
clay to make these wedge cuneus shapes
forms cuneiform so the mana Genesis
story goes everyone else steals
cuneiform and Rees skins it to fit their
own needs it's not a popular story these
days given what we know about Chinese
and especially Mesoamerican writing
along with some very early Egyptian
finds whoever's first in these early
days of writing all the civilizations
start manufacturing hordes of logographs
so many in fact that they unwittingly
unleash an epic memory burden on budding
ligaw offers from would-be ancient
scribes to beginning students of
Mandarin Chinese do they really need
this many characters to write surely
there's an easier way
say hello to this smart rogue who's
about to solve your problem with an
innocent mistake his father has been
counting sheep literally and he just
asked his son to record a measly line in
his budget ten sheep for uncle the son
writes the 10 and the logograph for
sheep but uncle he pauses and scratches
his head eager to play with his friends
he writes the character for ankle 10
sheep ankle he hurries away without a
second thought but don't take his
invention lightly if you've ever played
fill in the blank or guessing games
where you have to sound out picture
words you've seen and use this principle
for yourself but it's not just for
quirky puzzles with funny solutions the
name for this is another major moment in
the history of writing um the name for
this is is rebus this familiar language
game lets you look beyond the meaning of
a character and use it simply for its
sound son sounds like son and by
extension perhaps soon and sown
logographs like the symbol for sun could
already be read as words now with the
rebus principle in your pocket lokah
graphs can also be read as sounds this
isn't just useful for getting ancient
uncle his ancient sheep once Aztec city
planners finished building their
stunning Capitol in the middle of a lake
the Venice of the new world Tenochtitlan
their scribes needed a way to write its
name they've been using what amounts to
basic picture writing since Tenochtitlan
has a stone okay and a cactus no chilli
its natural to write it with two fairly
obvious glyphs then these become not
just symbols meaning cactus and stone
but symbols for the noises they know
titi blonde making them just as much
rebus fun as those puzzles you solved as
a kid and now you know the name for
those you also know why there's a cactus
on top of a stone in Mexico's flag it's
not just for show
howlite does the sound-alike
pronunciation have to be which sounds
can we chop off pit the Egyptians
against the Sumerians one more time
Egyptian hieroglyphs cut off the initial
consonant or less often two or three
consonants from the original word
Sumerians on the other hand with their
cuneiform take whole syllables these two
paths don't just add some local flavor
Reba sing out consonants doesn't just
impact ancient Egyptian hieroglyphs it
leaves a legacy for later spin-offs the
mentality that these are either read as
logographs or they stand for consonants
Kanaya form leaves a different legacy
completely unrelated languages will
spend thousands of years of borrowing
and reborrowing cuneiform to write their
own words but each time the symbols are
read as logographs or as syllables
flexibility is key here look at this
Egyptian hieroglyph it can be read as
the logograph for mouth gray or is the
consonant or this character could be
read as the logograph meaning helps or
it could stand for the consonant / the
two consonants in the Egyptian word
conveniently in Egyptian the little / e
below lets you know when it's appear
logograph the rebus discovery brings up
the tension between meaning and sound is
writing phonetic or semantic is it about
encoding the meaning of words or
encoding speech sounds the old
logographs were fundamentally a meaning
writing system sure this sounds like rey
in Egyptian but what's crucial is that
this is a local graph for the word
meaning mouth rebus writing takes a big
step towards sound writing this will
come to stand for the consonant order
regardless of meaning it may come as a
surprise but once discovered sound
writing doesn't ask meaning writing not
at all indeed early writers notice that
phonetic writing brings up a problem a
problem you probably missed because of
your comfort with sound writing a
problem that meaning writing can solve
brace yourself history because
logographs are about to make a comeback
like all of the world's earliest writing
systems Chinese characters start out as
symbols that stand for words a rice
paddy a person a tree
these are logographs and they let you
depict specific language pieces to write
what you mean but instead of requiring
different characters for every word the
handy rebus principle lets you write
other things that sound like the
logograph to write what you say sure you
could use the rebus sounds like
principle to write any sound in your
language but please consider this symbol
and answer the question that follows
does it mean
son soon son or sone oh my did rebus
writing get you into a bit of trouble
here when we see this character we could
read it as a plain old logograph
according to its meaning or any of these
rebus ways following its pronunciation
which one should you choose think a bit
outside of the Jade box here and take
the lead of this Han scribe his solution
is elegant don't choose one use both
systems together what's that behind his
back is that a oh yeah major moments in
the history of writing so here's the
logograph for horse but it also sounds
the same as the word for ant so the
rebus principle lets us write them both
with the same glyph confusing not if you
add the logograph for insect next to the
sound alike character this says it's
pronounced like horse which it is but
that its meaning has something to do
with insect you don't read the extra
character it's a meaning hint
determining how to read the sound
character so it's called a determinative
one more Mandarin example this logograph
means moon which happens to be
pronounced ua using rebus writing you a
also means amputate your feet
incidentally the word key is pronounced
the same way same problem but nothing a
couple determinatives can't fix add the
determinative for metal to this
character add knife to that one and
let's leave the moon be because that's
already what it means here again the
sounds like reading of a character gives
you its phonetic component this extra
logograph Clues you
to its meaning its semantic component
together they form a unit a whole
character with a clear meaning and a
clear pronunciation determinative z' are
very common in Chinese characters
natively called Han characters in fact
since they hint at the characters root
meaning its radix Homme determinatives
get called radicals bringing back the
characters son it can be pronounced in
many ways true but at a determinative a
silent helper character and you can
quickly narrow down its meaning these
extra determinatives avoid ambiguous
readings which one is the Sun in the sky
which is a father son which one means
soon too easy there's something else to
learn from this quiet scribe he's using
radicals to clean up some ambiguity but
even he knows that context matters
he won't spell everything out for you
every time
sometimes this character means four as
in this is for you
other times it's the verb supply he's
balancing this tension in the history of
writing between what's easy on the
reader who needs more information to
interpret the words versus what's easy
on the writer who typically knows what
he means when he's writing it plus hand
cramps the choice of leaving in or
leaving out helpful information isn't
simply about clarity and laziness its
aesthetic throughout the history of
Chinese calligraphy from Oracle loans to
the rough cursive script stylistic
choices are made not just semantics and
phonetic choices seeing through the
calligraphers eyes you can find in the
history of writing not only a vision of
what words and sounds look like but
where words and sounds go and where they
stop when it comes to aesthetic choices
and Han characters none is more
fundamental than the decision to arrange
character components in blocks bonus
note this is definitely not the only
time in history that writing gets
organized in blocks so this radical sits
on top of this phonetic component in a
block making up one whole character the
character for flower the ideograph man
plus tree a man leaning against a tree
has two components sitting side by side
in a block and there the character for
rest and here's one tree in its own
block two trees meaning
woods and three trees for forest
aesthetics aside what would happen if we
took this sound like principle a step
further and made writing about the
sounds isn't that a better solution to
our soon Sun sown Sun problem and one
that doesn't make us memorize tons of
characters
a Maya stone worker h's elaborate rows
of characters onto a steel ax a tall
stone brought in from far away that's
now standing straight up in the middle
of the city the characters he's carving
look more like detailed pictures than
writing but don't let that fool you take
a look at this block it means mountain
but it's not a logograph standing for
mountain it's not a rebus symbol for
think of a word that rhymes with SH
Mountain it's actually a block of to
sound symbols that spell the word wheats
the Maya word for mountain that's great
for climbers but chocolate lovers may
instead prefer to sample these three
symbols that together spell the word
cacao cocoa there's a nifty shortcut
here this bit doesn't even mean kha it's
actually a syllable multiplier or
iteration mark if you want the fancy
name Shh I think you're being watched
over there in the jungle maybe not hmm
major moments in the history of writing
both of these Maya glyphs combined
syllable characters into blocks to write
words this is full-fledged sound writing
these aren't logographs that happen to
be read as sounds they are sounds sounds
capable of writing any syllable in the
language in a full syllabary like the
classical Maya script there are separate
characters for just about every possible
syllable in the language no longer must
you invent new word characters you can
make do with a much smaller set of
syllable characters nice but syllable
writing comes with its own set of
problems here's a glyph that's quite
useful around these parts Jaguar the
word is actually Balaam but have you
noticed something about the Mayan
syllabary consonant plus vowel consonant
plus vowel more consonants plus more
vowels all of these syllables Indian
vowels how in the world are you supposed
to write the lung in balaam Shifty's
script e syllabaries have grappled with
this problem and settled on two
solutions one leave out the final letter
just ignore it
the term for this is under spelling
because you're not fully spelling the
word and it's a good solution because
you know ignoring your problems makes
them go away option to spell the last
letter with an extra syllable they use a
syllable that just repeats the last
vowel so that we know we can just ignore
the final vowel this gets called the
echo vowel Mayan likes number two a lot
so cacao is cacao WA well kha times two
waa wheats the mountain is actually with
Si and your new pet Balam is spelled ba
la ma cross out the echo vowels and the
words practically read themselves your
new friend pulls you along to show you
another project he's working on Anna
MAHT a codex that's a paper book yes he
has paper and yes books but that's not
what's got him excited he folds open the
book he's working on maybe to share new
ideas no to brag about how inventive and
potentially efficient his writing system
is no for his people the invention of
the new wasn't about ditching the old he
shows you how creative he's been with
the characters you learned he shows you
a mountain and calls it wheats and then
a Jaguar and calls it Balam logographs
wait a second you stop and ask him which
is the correct way to write Balam he
writes ba llama you ask him to write it
again
and he writes the logograph but with a
syllable and again but he writes the
logograph plus two syllables
he smiles mischievously they're all
Balam this is what he's proud of he can
write the same word even the same
syllable in different ways and
combinations without repeating himself
creative but his use of logographs plus
syllables recalls the tension between
sound writing and meaning writing
meaningful determinative z' helped us
choose the right pronunciation for our
rebus character and Mayan logographs can
still do that but the helping hand goes
both ways the syllabary can also clarify
the sounds you should make when you read
a lower graph here's the character
Jaguar but add a couple extra syllable
hints and you
get clear that were meant to read this
glyph as ba llama - the echo vowel so
Balaam these are phonetic complements
pronunciation clues sitting comfortably
alongside logographs if that's all too
complex just remember that you can write
everything in syllables but before you
have time to settle into this land of
Balaam and cacao to practice those
syllables a Sandy wind starts blowing in
from the east
a familiar reminder from a far away land
where even more dramatic changes are
about to shape the future of writing
even in these ancient times Egyptian
monuments have been sitting and
weathering for thousands of years on
their great murals and pillars you find
rows of little pictures
sorry not pictures hieroglyphs sacred
symbols but despite appearances this
isn't some mysterious fairy onic picture
writing its consonants one consonant
signs two consonant signs three
consonant signs a wall of consonants
plus a sprinkle of logographs for
determinatives it's not that Egyptian
was a harsh vowel less desert of a
tongue it simply did not write at the
vowels imagine if you wrote this way
would that work and then imagine if you
could add in logographs to make sure you
really got your point across imagine you
wrote like that and you're thinking with
hieroglyphs too difficult fine off to
the caves with you where you toil away
with ancient miners on the Sinai
Peninsula you and your fellow miners
would find it handy to leave messages
for one another but there's no time for
deep studies of rows of fancy
hieroglyphs in here you need to keep it
simple if you want another major moments
in the history of writing your
characters look like scratchy rushed
version of those glamorous Egyptian
symbols but their meaning doesn't matter
anymore nothing but consonants and the
same symbol for the same consonant every
time take this character in Egyptian it
means house
these Semitic miners are calling a house
a bit acropole or top sounds suggest
that you can just take the first letter
of a word like the Egyptians had already
been doing with much of their consonant
writing you end up with a letter for
your sound but do the same thing with
water which the Semitic speakers are
calling mem and you now have an mm sound
with a couple dozen elegant
simplifications you create a simple
reliable list of consonants an alphabet
and you've given generations of future
children the joys of reciting their ABCs
actually at this point in history there
a B G DS sometimes called an abjad or
abroad because who needs that
wishy-washy C when you can just use an S
or a K after a long hard day of mining
and etching you turn to find that
someone's been watching you this whole
time she's a traitor a Phoenician
merchant who knows a good thing when she
sees it she's already made major cash in
the paper business where they turned
tough t stocky swampy Egyptian papyrus
into flat ink couple sheets of paper she
rushes back home to Phoenicia and smirks
think of the advantage she has keeping
track of whatever anyone else tells her
just by remembering about as many
characters as she has fingers and toes
old Kings can keep their obtuse
hieroglyphs and their stone monuments
the future of the Mediterranean will
belong to alphabets and paper writing is
going portable she uses this newfound
alphabetic leverage to turn a huge
profit across the entire eastern
Mediterranean leaving people inspired to
adopt and adopt her alphabet wherever
she goes all this and she doesn't even
write you a thank-you card
how hard could it be writing is easier
than ever
it feels universal like writings here to
stay for everyone but there's a peculiar
quirk that's easier to spot in hindsight
you and your mining crew we're
communicating in a semitic language
Phoenicians a Semitic language all of
these friendly shades of the Phoenician
alphabet were being used for languages
that sounded similar and worked much the
same way even Egyptian though no Semitic
language itself is at least a distant
relative of the Semitic languages with a
similar personality this consonant
alphabet is being tested in easy waters
but history is shaking things up your
merchant friend comes back for your help
she needs you to deliver your alphabet
to a very different people living along
her trade route
what will happen when the alphabet gets
leaked outside of the family
Greece no not that Greece Greece before
there was a Parthenon a stern old man in
a trademark sporty toga seems a bit on
edge as he glares at the papyrus sheet
clutched in his hand
ah you see you try to shrug off his
outburst but he can't let this go my
friend my friend he recounts how five
hundred years before he was even born
when the walls of Troy still stood the
Greeks had a writing system of their own
it was one of those more elaborate
syllabary plus logograph types but that
script had come and it had gone the new
Greeks were people on the rise but an
illiterate people on the rise a people
looking for something new something
great and this alphabet thing seems
great
almost he calls over his close friends
the Phoenician consonants are useful he
concedes but why these extra characters
for huffing coughing and clearing your
throat
these are barbarian sounds Greeks have
no need for them and what about the
voicing noises like oh and whew how to
write them huh so much extra yet so much
missing what a mess you try to explain
but they laugh it off
here I fix for you he says see he was
going to ditch the mmm-hmm barbarian
letters but he had second thoughts and
it struck him why not use these on break
sounds for vowels
the one you call LF ignore the throaty
catch at the beginning its ah take that
hey but ditch the huh and we're left
with a vowel e a loosen up that tight
wah in wall and it's the vowel mmm
this isn't just a small correction this
is a powerful major moment in the
history of writing he's fundamentally
shifted the way the alphabet functions
it used to be just the consonant
suggesting the pronunciation of a word
once you recognize the word the jobs
done but Greek spelling isn't merely
about writing recognizable words it's
about matching letters to sounds a new
principle has just emerged perhaps even
a new goal one sound one character you
suspect that he's not even aware of the
impact of his discovery as he tells you
to drop everything and come enjoy some
dinner and dancing who'd be silly the
party goes on and on so long that your
new friends don't even see what's
happening beyond the walls of their
city-state this consonant vowel alphabet
this pronunciation writing is spreading
inspiring new alphabets to the east with
flavors like Armenian and Cyrillic
popping up out west in Italy the Tuscans
the Etruscans borrow it and they pass it
on to the Romans the Romans burst out
and splatter it among the celts and
germanic peoples and eventually the
world such a visual rainbow of
variations and yet they'll all stick
with the basic principle of writing a
character for each sound consonants and
vowels finally you see your writing
system in this story your alphabet all
because a handful of semitic symbols got
mistaken for greek vowels but before you
get overconfident know that the history
of writing doesn't stop here this isn't
the be-all and end-all not even close
you're back in old Phoenicia where it
turns out the Greeks aren't the only
ones looking to buy a vowel your contact
in town is still your merchant frenemy
who reminds you of how she traded your
consonant alphabet across the ancient
world that objet to every language with
even a passing resemblance to
Phoenicians every town from here to
carthage has some version of her objet
spot the Egyptians those stuck in their
way traditionalists initially these
Semitic speakers loved it they were
proud of it
but the days are turning to years and
that love grows cold they grumble that
they're stuck with these consonants just
consonants clamoring for vowels they get
desperate and grab a few characters to
stand in for a long sound take a look
this symbol is originally the stop
between ha this one's a why a you sound
and this is a one but they're about to
become not these things thanks to major
moments in the history of writing this
moment hits you twice because it brings
up both an innovation specific to
semitic scripts and a more general
principle that kind of bends the rules
of the alphabet game first it's worth
reiterating that objects are viable ways
to write and read a language they work
but with one obvious shortcoming those
missing vowels can create ambiguous
situations but what if instead of
writing every vowel we just had a few
helpful hint ORS that suggested the
presence of certain kinds of vowels take
this letter what actually they called it
Wow Wow
now imagine that we keep using it in
words that have the sound what but we
also extend its use placing it between
consonants for the similar enough vowel
sound whew in the old objet have to
write soon and son with the same
characters s plus in everything else is
vowels and we don't have those but
suddenly our extended walk comes in
handy son doesn't have that sound so
it's still s plus in but soon does so we
add in the W do the same thing with you
which can double as a long eye and this
quirky catch in your throat pause
between uh-oh LF which can double as
along ah and you
end up with three handy vowels adjusters
the mantras lectio nice these helpful
mothers of reading that show up in
aramaic hebrew arabic and Syriac but
these mothers don't leave their
consonant 'no spend they still double as
consonants the object raided the
ambiguity of a vowel this existence for
new kind of ambiguity depending on
context each of these mattress may be a
consonant or it might be a vowel one
character multiple sounds this is a huge
trend in alphabet why invent new
characters when you can reuse an old one
repurposing consonants for vowels here
and there won't satisfy everyone these
bickering scribes aren't content with
mattress elecciones they're not just
trying to tell son apart from soon the
bickering scribes are bickering over how
to read one of their most treasured
sayings one says that it's such a fine
point you wouldn't understand unless you
were incredibly well versed in his
language but he makes an analogy for you
write the word news in a consonant only
alphabet it's in WS fine now imagine
that someone comes along with their
fancy consonant vowel hybrids and spells
the word noose in WS hmm wait a second
he shows you a cheat sheet he's been
keeping it's so easy he says pointing
out the little dots and dashes above and
below letters to keep his vowel straight
put them here for an oo there for an A
you can even add them below one of the
long vowel things if you need to
distinguish say an e nobody's confused
that's it
he won't tolerate the vagueness any
longer effective immediately in all
important texts we're clear reading
matters everyone's to use this method
and so for generations scribes with mark
vowels above and below the consonants
writing vowels in what was once a
consonant only alphabet but as much as
the pious and students swear by their
dotty vowels modern Arabic and Hebrew
speakers stick with the simple
consonants plus the extended consonant
vowel mothers the optional helper dots
get thrown in like a life preserver for
struggling learners or careful texts but
grown-ups don't need them anymore
a spice market in India the hooded
figure in front of you apologizes for
the kidnapping he needs your help he
explains that his land has taken part in
history's most elaborate and rigorous
memorization exercises instead of
scribes they had recitations
these weren't retellings of campfire
stories these were whole libraries of
knowledge handed down for generations he
says his name is Ashoka this is his land
and he is king after a bloody and
violent war he had a change of heart
and now has but one singular focus to
spread his message a law of tolerance
and compassion throughout the land but
he doesn't want to use the mouth to ear
memorization ways of the oral tradition
that's for old texts and old ideas no
his vision is to install massive pillars
around his empire each one engraved with
his list of edicts this he explains is
where you come in see he's been keeping
tabs on you as you roam the land of the
Semitic objects this crazy consonant
alphabet idea he'll take it but he also
appreciates the whimsical simplicity of
accenting consonants with vowel marks oh
and he doesn't want to have to write the
vowel if it's just a short uh his
language is full of those so he'll write
funnel something like this with these
built-in syllables but wait it's not fun
Allah that final all is in a separate
syllable he needs a way to write just
bare consonants to tell his past apart
from his pasta how with a simple hush
stroke below the letter now he brags to
you his system is complete make sure you
don't miss the step he's taking here
it's a major moment in the history of
writing each of the character units
fundamentally represents a syllable it
just so happens that unless the vowel in
that syllable is a short aw the vowel
gets added onto or below or beside the
consonant character on their own the
base characters contain that dummy vowel
up like puffs but you can take that puh
and modify it with any vowel you like
certain
owls go in certain places like e to the
side or ooh below so in India characters
are syllables but unlike a full
syllabary you don't need a completely a
separate character for each separate
syllable and all characters give
consonant plus vowel information but
unlike a full alphabet you don't line up
sequences of consonants plus vowels
consonants plus vowels the hybrid
combination nature of the system earns
it the name alpha syllabary combos are
built into this system paving the way
for over a thousand ligatures commonly
linked characters in the Alpha syllabary
sure other writing systems developed
ligatures in their calligraphy but the
Indic Alpha syllabary welcomes them
naturally as it's passed all around this
entire slice of the world up to Nepal in
Tibet down the coast to Burma Thailand
Laos Cambodia and Beyond the script
keeps updating its look but continues to
capture consonants and vowels accurately
like an alphabet and to write those
vowels consonants and syllable units
like the syllabary even completely
unrelated alpha syllabaries seized on
this same idea this is the ethiopia
symbol for MA this one reads Mei and
this is mu this is law play and loop now
that you understand off with syllabaries
you must answer this next question if
this symbol sounds like ba how do you
write BAE and boo in Ethiopia this is
your get is ABC DS the abugida
looks different but works much the same
way your characters have never looked so
different even after the Greeks and
Romans took them over maybe it's this
dizzying variety of writing systems or
maybe thoughts pill is starting to wear
off
another time another king this time in a
Korean palace he presents himself as
King Sejong as you get a grip on your
surroundings you begin to tell him of
your journeys yet with a sweeping gaze
the king looks right past you you've
been out for a very long time over a
thousand years the world has come so far
and the scripts you once knew have - he
reminds you of the old Chinese
logographs and sound meaning
combinations those are still useful to
his court to a point you see Chinese has
these nice word units one after another
but Korean he boast has these elegantly
complex words with different pieces and
endings fitting Chinese writing to
Korean grammar hasn't been easy he tells
you of a people across the sea who've
gone through a similar struggle the
Japanese simplified Chinese characters
by turning them into a fixed syllabary
which they now use alongside the Chinese
characters so they have these syllable
characters and these thousands of Han
characters they use the Han characters
for the meaning heavy components
vocabulary terms then they use the
syllabary to write little grammatical
words and word pieces or new vocabulary
words that don't historically have their
own chinese logograph such a complicated
system gentlemen the king has an almost
puzzled look like he's holding back a
punch line he recounts how in old Japan
women wrote entire books using only the
syllable characters because writing with
the traditional Han characters was seen
as the masculine thing to do but he
knows of another land he's heard exotic
tales of the west where people write out
all of their sounds logically he pauses
he can't quite grasp this himself you
snicker as you think back on how you saw
the alphabet develop with your own eyes
in your journeys you would know so you
sit down and show him how to write every
vowel and consonant with the alphabet
a couple dozen shapes and you can write
any sound you smile and think so simple
but he lets out an unimpressed sigh why
do all the characters look so different
so haphazard I mean you make fun and
voix by putting your bottom lip against
your top teeth the only difference is
that your throat vibrates when you say
wha
he quizzes you why do you write fuh and
voix and he goes on interrogating you
what about BA why does it look that way
when it's just taking the bus sound and
saying it through smacked lips seems you
underestimated the king he doesn't want
any old alphabet he wants a writing
system that shows the various features
of sounds that the sound is made in your
throat against your teeth made with your
lips and so on he puts his brightest
scholars to work giving them the humble
name of the Hall of worthies in go the
experts and out comes another major
moments in the history of writing they
develop Korean Hangul a featural
alphabet every syllable gets separated
out into its own block the syllables
consonants and vowels will be written
side by side within that block each
consonant and vowel letter inside that
block will be shaped according to its
features so here are the consonants that
get pronounced with the lips see the
similar lip shape here's da and here is
cut again similar sounds similar shape
the featural alphabet was so simple and
straightforward that one of the king's
historians almost dared people to learn
it if you're smart you can learn it in
one morning if you're a fool it'll take
you ten days not everyone's jumping on
the Hangul easy train community
accessible writing bothers
traditionalists who skip out on the
innovation and keep using Chinese
characters fitted to Korean hanja or
hand characters even into the 1900s
still for the rest writing is easier
than ever it has its first rock star it
even gets its own holiday o writing
you've come a long long way from
pictographs in a cave
the day that thoughts invented writing
famis warned him that he discovered a
drug that would make people lose touch
with themselves if you're still watching
you took thoughts pill and saw for
yourself the effects it really had it
started with visual depictions of the
world pictographs signs for ideas and
thoughts ideographs then a
transformation from picture writing to
true writing with symbols that stand for
words logographs
using those word symbols to stand for
similar sounding words rebus then those
sound-alikes became syllable characters
syllabaries consonant characters
and vowel characters alphabets or even
consonant vowel syllables alpha
syllabaries and if things get really
linguistic savvy alphabets become all
featural characters grouped by their
phonetic properties along the way of
writing had to deal with tensions and
take sides should it represent meanings
or sounds should it benefit the reader
or the writer contain maximum
information about every sound or just
enough to recognize the shape of a word
should it be flexible and creative or
rigid and consistent how do physical
techniques shape it oh and who did it
first who did it best maybe you've
learned to make some sense out of the
chaotic noise of world writing systems
maybe you can appreciate some of the
problems each one solves the traditions
it captures the ambiguities it creates
or perhaps it's more comfortable just to
close your eyes and wake up back at home
looking at your familiar characters of
your familiar writing system plastered
across your favorite websites
still so how you can't even look at that
the same way it's just one invention
among many in the long history of this
language technology we call writing
you